so i'm here with walter isaacson of the
aspen institute and it looks like we're
going to be talking about benjamin
franklin
so so one question i have is you know
he's clearly considered one of the
founding fathers
but he's the one that was never
president
and so why do we care so much about him
you know he's the unintimidating founder
the one who winks at us from history
stage he's older than the rest so by the
time we have a country you know he's in
his late 80s a little too old to be
president
but he's the one who the glue who brings
us together he also helps invent the
american character that sort of spunky
chatty populist democratic person who
wants to bring people together and you
know form a new type of nation based on
the unity of various different types of
peoples and ethnic groups so he gets
that america is going to be a
middle-class nation more even than
george washington or jefferson or
madison or john adams who are much more
from the elite you know this is a
shopkeeper he's middle class
and and and so just to get a sense of
his
life you know we have a timeline up here
and i
drew the timeline ahead of time because
i i do find it confusing i mean he
wasn't in america his whole life and he
wasn't in one town his whole life yeah
he was you know during he lived 84 years
and he was america's best scientist an
inventor diplomat writer business
strategist and one of the most practical
of our uh political thinkers and he does
it in various phases of his life he's
born in boston the tenth son of an
immigrant i mean of a of a
puritan
refugee to boston
and he runs away as a kid so then he
goes to london for a little while to buy
printing equipment to work and make
enough money to buy printing equipment
and then he comes to philadelphia as a
you know in his early 20s in order to be
a printer and then he becomes a great
businessman he not only has a print shop
but he has a newspaper a publishing
business he franchises his print shops
up and down the coast he creates the
american postal system in order to tie
together a lot of his printing and
publishing houses
and then semi retires in philadelphia to
become a civic leader to do things like
his electricity experiments which were
very important but also to do things
like founding a lot of civic groups like
the you know what becomes the university
of pennsylvania and so most of that
period he's become a middle class
shopkeeper and then become sort of the
head of the you know good business group
in philadelphia this is this is a pretty
interesting period because you know as
he likes to recount he kind of showed up
in philadelphia penniless
at a fairly young age and then over this
time period he becomes as you just
mentioned kind of a leader of his
community that is another reason why
he's the american archetype he's our
first self-made man he's a horatio alger
myth the rags to riches he does take
great pride in his autobiography talking
about coming into philadelphia with only
three coins in his pocket all bedraggled
and yet his remarkable rise in the world
he calls it when he opens a print shop
does the newspaper creates poor
richard's almanac suddenly he's the most
successful business entrepreneur in all
of the american colonies and uh that's
the first time we've ever had in our
history a person who was just a poor
runaway become one of the richest and
most successful businessmen and just to
understand his and we'll go do other
videos where we go into more depth in
all of these periods but why did he you
know he ran away he was working for his
brother and he just didn't get along
well he was apprenticed to his brother
and that's something that's interesting
when you look at the early colonies an
apprenticeship
is when you sign over that you're going
to work seven eight years until you're
at least 21
for somebody else you don't you don't
you get just at most uh small wages and
you're bound it's not of course like
being a slave but it's also not like
being a free man you were bound as an
apprentice and that he started and he
was apprenticed under his brother at age
12. who was a printer and ran a
newspaper in boston and franklin does
not this makes him an american too he
doesn't like arbitrary authority he
doesn't like his brother being his boss
he doesn't like the theocratic authority
in boston he wants freedom so he runs
away and he and so he literally had to
run away because he owed his brother
time as an apprentice right he had
signed an indenture he was an apprentice
to his brother he could not he could
legally leave he actually pulls off a
little trick on his brother because his
brother has to pretend that ben is
running the newspaper because his
brother's in a little bit of trouble so
with that trick he knew that his brother
could not send somebody out to capture
him late at night he runs away by sea
leaves boston and ends up
about a week later bedraggled and wet
and almost penniless in philadelphia but
then he immediately goes to london why
does he go to london this time period
well he wants to be a printer
and they're you know this is the good
old days they're about 10 newspapers in
philadelphia he wants to make the 11th
he wants a friendship he had worked for
his brother as a printer his brother was
a printer so that's the trade he knew
but in order to be a printer you had to
have a printing press and fonts and
stuff like that so he runs away
uh to philadelphia to set up shop and he
realizes he needs to buy the printing
equipment yeah and he wants to go to
london himself to get it and one of his
backers in philadelphia an older man he
met said he would pay for it but the guy
reneged on the deal so franklin goes to
london and has to get a job there in
order to make enough money to buy his
printing equipment
i said that's why he had to stay there
get the equipment come back and that's
kind of what launched his yeah and then
he comes back with his printing
equipment a couple years later and
that's what launches him on his career
as a publisher and printer and it was
really kind of near the end of this
phase i guess his midlife that as you
mentioned he's a civic leader inventor
and we'll talk more about that in depth
and that's kind of what launches him
into
his role as a i guess
founding father well exactly he becomes
a civic leader in philadelphia he
becomes a bit of a political leader in
philadelphia in the assembly and then
pennsylvania as a colony decides it
needs an ambassador to london because
we're having all the problems with the
british parliament and they're ministers
and they're imposing taxes and they're
doing all sorts of bad things and so
he's like being an ambassador
of the colonies to uh london he was
appointed by the pennsylvania assembly
but four or five other colonies
massachusetts and others decide well
we'll we'll use him too he'll be our
ambassador as well you've got to
remember we were not one country back
then we were just a collection of
colonies so each of the colonies had to
decide who to send as their ambassador
so he spends a lot of time you know
really over
you know almost a 20-year period off and
on in london acting as an ambassador of
the colonies trying to keep us uh
together as an empire prevent the
american revolution
but in 1775 he basically fails comes
back to philadelphia in 1776
uh becomes part of the continental
congress
and helps write the declaration of
independence
and then right after they do it he has
to go to paris even though he's bit old
by then because in order to make the
declaration a reality we had to get
france in our side in the war so there's
about nine years in paris acting as an
ambassador to paris and he's successful
in getting
france in on our side in the war
and then as a pretty old man as he's
pushing 80 he comes back to what is then
the united states
and helps write the constitution of the
constitutional convention and is a very
elder statesman
wow
fascinating life oh it's totally amazing
and in american life too it helps define
what an american is and what our country
is